okay I can't believe I have to say a Qi
[ __ ] hug him we ask members of the
BuzzFeed community to tell us the
grossest thing they've ever done for
their partner these are their stories
Lauren writes we went out of town for a
night away from our sons and I was still
breastfeeding I forgot to pack my pump
and my breasts became so engorged I was
in tears nothing I did would ridiculous
nothing I did would release the milk
into the hotel sink so he sucked the
milk until my flow started Wow I mean
whom stir among us hasn't sucked milk I
feel like he gave me the [ __ ] boob
second one on purpose
Whitney writes he complained of an
irritated itchy [ __ ] I got on my
hands and knees spread his cheeks apart
and examined it with my phone flashlight
it doesn't stop there he felt such
relief when my finger accidentally
grazed the hemorrhoid that I let him lie
across my lap for 20 minutes while I
scratched his [ __ ] that is true love
that's a very good
Natalie writes my ex-boyfriend had the
quote post rave poop if you know what I
mean I don't we were so high that I
stood by the door talking to him and he
asked if I would sit with him while he
proved so I sat on the floor while he
took a [ __ ] I don't understand why you
need company for that but I guess it's a
it's just a Rick just rave things Eric
writes my ex-girlfriend had the string
from a tampon break-off somehow she
convinced me that I was the only one
that could get it out so I called my mom
who's a nurse and asked her to bring
some latex gloves to me after work and
yeah I gloved up and got that little
bastard out of there I felt like a hero
that's gross it's interesting that he
was the one that had to do it I think
that there might be some other options
in that situation Kalyan writes we went
for a hike and came back to our cabin a
few hours later I was in the kitchen
while he was showering and out of
nowhere he comes around the corner
butt-naked and soaking wet looking
rather uncomfortable he had a tick on
his ball sack the next half-hour was
spent with him sprawled out on the floor
and me examining his staff trying to
figure out the best way to get the tick
off dish soap ended up saving the day oh
and did I mention we were on our
honeymoon
the things you do for love Tara writes
my fiance had an epidermal cyst on the
back of his neck he'd had it for a few
years when one day he got a spot on top
of it which I popped for him naturally
which then led to the cyst starting to
leak over two days I helped him squeeze
in a hole out and dress it and disinfect
it it was the most disgusting thing I
have ever seen I don't know just the
phrase dressing or wound that just
reminds me of like the Civil War
something Oh amber writes my husband
noticed a bump on his penis
after inspection I guessed it was a
pimple and offered to get rid of it this
is not gonna end good five minutes later
he sees me in the bathroom on my knees
with a needle poking this thing in him
trying not to pass out as I squeezed it
I noticed not much was coming out so I
got up close and personal right about
this time I was three inches away it
exploded and shot puss in my eye
and all over my hair as penis puss all
over the eyes all over the airs I wish I
never had to read that this is insane
why would you ever share this with
anyone this is something you take to the
grave
[Music]